the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another song of ice and fire
video
for those of you that don't know i made
a series of videos where i went over
some of my favorite moments from the
song of ice and fire books
in those videos i showed you how certain
scenes were different from the show
like the red wedding danny's visions at
the house of the undying
bran stark's flashbacks when he's inside
the weirwood and so many more
in this video i want to show you what
happens when oberyn martell
fights gregor clegane the mountain vs
the red viper is easily one of the
greatest fight scenes to ever be shown
in a television show
but now i want you to see how it
happened in the book a storm of swords
i hope you enjoy the video especially
for those of you who have not read the
books yet
now i don't know about all of you but
when i saw this episode for the first
time
i was completely stunned by what
happened i don't think i necessarily
expected oberyn to win the fight but
when i saw
him moving around out there it was
obvious he had a good chance
it was just one of those amazing moments
in television history
i had never seen anything quite like
that before and i'd never really seen
anything like it since
so let's see how it was written in the
book as you all know
this all started because tyrion
lannister was held responsible for the
death of his nephew joffrey baratheon
he poisoned my son after he was thrown
in a cell
he would soon realize his life would
never be the same again
his father tywin lannister and his
sister
cersei lannister would never let him
walk away from this
this is when tyrion thought he might
have better odds if he let the gods
decide his fate
so he demanded a trial by combat i will
not give my life for joffrey's murder
and i know i'll get no justice here so i
will let the gods decide my
fate i demand
a trial by combat
once it was known gregor clegane would
be fighting for joffrey or should i say
cersei
this is when oberyn wanted to get
involved after all
this was the moment he had been waiting
for because now he had a chance to
avenge his sister elia martell
and her children who were slain at the
hands of the mountain that rides
i'm asking your question i've heard
rumors
so am i what i keep hearing is that
gregor cleganed the mountain
raped elia and split her in half with
his great sword
i wasn't there i don't know what if the
mountain killed my sister your father
gave the order
on the day of the fight tyrion thought
it seemed if oberyn was in a hurry to
get there
because of his short legs almost
everyone could walk faster than tyrion
but he noticed oberyn was very eager for
the fight to begin
he thought the snake is eager let's hope
he is venomous as well
this day was grey and windy the sun was
barely breaking through the clouds when
they first arrived
now you would have thought this was a
sold out event tyrion thinks there must
be a thousand people here waiting for
the fight
they were all standing elbow to elbow as
they lined the castle wall walks and
stood on the steps of the towers
they were watching from the stable doors
windows and bridges
from roofs and balconies there were so
many watching and waiting
the gold cloaks and the knights of the
kingsguard had to shove them back just
to make enough room for the fight
tyrion thought they should have held
this event at a larger venue
and sold tickets because they could have
made enough money to cover joffrey's
wedding and funeral
some of the onlookers even had small
children sitting on their shoulders to
get a better view
everyone begins shouting when they saw
tyrion arrive
you would have thought this was the
super bowl and tyrion was the captain of
the most hated team
when he sees cersei standing next to sir
gregor clegane
he thinks she looks like a child in his
armor
the mountain looked bigger than any man
had any right to be he looked as if he
was made out of stone
his greatsword was sticking into the
ground before him
six feet of scarred metal sir gregor's
giant hands were cladding gauntlets of
lobstered steel
he wore heavy armor over his chain mail
doll gray steel
dented and scarred from battles before
under that he wore
boiled leather for his head he wore a
great helm that had a narrow slit for
his visor the crest atop it was a stone
fist
the sight of him even shocked oberyn's
lady ellaria san
who said you're going to fight that
oberyn carelessly responded with
i'm going to kill that tyrion was not so
sure
he had his own doubts now that they
stood on the brink
when he looked at oberyn he found
himself wishing he had brawn defending
him instead
or even better his brother jaime
unfortunately tyrion had to take what he
could get
if it wasn't for oberyn seeking
vengeance for his family
he might not have found anyone else
willing to fight for him
the red viper was lightly armored but he
was mostly wearing leather and silk
when he sees what he's wearing he thinks
dance around him until he's so tired he
can hardly lift his arm
then lay him flat out on his back oberyn
seemed to have the same notion as braun
the only difference was braun also
talked about the downside to that
strategy
oberyn did not he was extremely
confident
running high off emotions lord tywin was
sitting up on a high platform that had
been erected beside the tower of the
hand
that set right in between both fighters
he glanced at his centurion
only briefly then lifted his hand that's
when a dozen horns blew to silence the
crowd
the high septon shuffled forward and
prayed that the father above would help
them in this judgment
and that the warrior should lend his
strength to the arm of the man whose
cause was
just that would be me tyrion almost
shouted
but he knew they would only laugh he was
sick of their laughter
sir osmond kettleblack brought gregor
clegane his shield
a massive thing of heavy oak rimmed in
black iron
as the mountain slid his left farm
through the straps tyrion saw that the
hounds of clegane were decorating the
front of it
there was 50 yards of open space between
the fighters
oberyn advanced quickly sir gregor more
ominously
the ground does not shake when he walks
tyrion told himself
that was only his heart fluttering when
the men were only 10 yards apart from
each other
the red viper stopped and called out
have they told you who i
am sir gregor grunted and said some dead
man
then he rushed forward the dornishmen
slid sideways
i am ober and martel a prince of dorney
said
as the mountain turned to keep him in
his sight princess elia was my sister
who asked gregor clegane auburn's long
spear
jabbed but sir gregor blocked it with
his shield then shoved it aside
and pulled back at oberon his great
sword flashing
the dornishmen spun away untouched his
spear darted forward again
clegane slashed at it oberyn snapped it
back then thrust again
metal screamed on metal as the spearhead
slid off the mountain's chest
slicing through the surcoat and leaving
a long bright scratch on the steel
beneath
sir gregor grunted again then he charged
it over and hacked at his head with his
greatsword
oberyn avoided him easily you raped her
you murdered her you killed her children
did you come to talk or to fight said
the mountain i came to hear you confess
the red viper landed a quick thrust on
the mountain's belly to no effect gregor
slashed at it but missed
the long spear lanced in above his sword
like a serpent's tongue
it flicked in and out fainting low and
landing high
jabbing at groin shield eyes the
mountain makes for a big target at the
least
tyrion thought oberyn was landing almost
all of his shots
the only issue was his spear was not
getting through gregor's heavy armor
regardless he kept circling jabbing then
darting back again
forcing the bigger man to turn and turn
again tyrion began to get excited when
he noticed
clegane was losing sight of his opponent
oberyn was lightning fast
the mountain's helmet had a narrow eye
slit severely limiting his vision
oberyn was taking advantage of that and
the length of his spear
and his quickness it went on that way
for what seemed like a long time
back and forth they moved across the
yard and round and round in circles
sir gregor slashing at the air while
uber spear struck at his arm
and leg and twice at his temple gregor's
big wooden shield took its share of hits
as well
gregor would grunt from time to time and
once tyrion heard him mutter a curse
but otherwise he fought in solemn
silence
not ober and martel you raped her he
called feigning
you murdered her he said dodging a
looping cut from gregor's greatsword
you killed her children he shouted
slamming the spear into the giant's
throat
only to have it glance off the thick
steel with the screech
you killed her children
oberyn is having fun with him said
ellaria sand this is a fool's game
thought tyrion the mountain is too
bloody big to be any man's toy
everyone who was standing and watching
the fight began to move in closer
inch by inch to get a better view the
kingsguard tried to keep them back
shoving at the gawkers forcefully with
their big white shields
but there were hundreds of them and only
six of the men in white armor
you raped her oberyn sent the spear
point at clegane's eyes
so fast the huge man flinched back you
killed her children
the spear flickered sideways and down
scraping against the mountain's armor on
his chest
the spear was two feet longer than sir
gregor's sword
more than enough to keep him at an
awkward distance he hacked at the shaft
whenever oberyn lunged at him
trying to cut off the spearhead but he
might as well been trying to hack the
wings off a fly
gregor tried to rush him but oberyn
skipped the side and circled round his
back
you raped her you murdered her you
killed her children
be quiet sir gregor seemed to be moving
a little slower
his greatsword no longer rose as high as
it had when the fight began
shut your bloody mouth yelled gregor you
raped her
oberyn said again as he moved to the
right shut up the mountain was beginning
to get frustrated
this is when he charged headlong right
at the front of the spear
which slammed into his breast then slid
aside with the hideous steel shriek
suddenly the mountain was close enough
to strike his huge sword flashing in a
steel blur
all of the spectators were screaming as
well oberyn slipped the first blow and
let go of the spear
useless now that sir gregor was inside
of it the second cut the dornishmen
caught on his shield
metal met metal with an ear splitting
clang sending the red viper reeling
sir gregor followed bellowing tyrion
thinks gregor doesn't use words
he just makes noises like an animal
oberyn retreat became a headlong
backward flight mere
inches ahead of the great sword as it
slashed at his chest
his arms and his head the stable was
right behind him
spectators screamed and shoved each
other to get out of the way
one of them stumbled right into oberyn's
back sir gregor hacked down with all of
his savage strength
the red viper threw himself sideways
rolling
the stable boy behind him was not so
fast right as his arms rose to shield
his face
gregor's sword took it off between elbow
and shoulder
shut up the mountain howled at the
stable boy's scream and this time he
swung the blade sideways
sending the top half of the lad's head
across the yard in a spray of blood and
brains
hundreds of spectators suddenly lost all
interest in the guilt or innocence of
tyrion lannister
judging by the way they all began to run
and shove each other to escape from the
yard
but the red viper of dorne was back on
his feet his long spear in his hand
ellia he called it sir gregor you raped
her
you murdered her you killed her children
now say her name after chopping off half
the man's head
the mountain was now covered in blood
from head to toe when he turned back to
oberyn
he said you talk too much you make my
head hurt
oberyn says i will hear you say it she
was elia of dorne
sir gregor clegane sprang into action
and in that moment
the sun broke through the low clouds
that had hit in the sky since dawn
the son of dorne tyrion told himself but
it was gregor clegane who moved first to
have the sun at his back
this is a dim and brutal man but he has
a warrior's instincts
the red viper crouched squinted his eyes
and sent his spear thrusting forward
again
sir gregor hacked at it but the thrust
had only been a faint
off-balance he stumbled forward a step
oberyn tilted his dented metal shield
a shaft of sunlight blazed blindly off
the shiny golden copper
into the narrow slit of his foe's helmet
clegane lifted his own shield against
the glare
then oberyn's spear flash like lightning
and found the gap in the heavy armor
in the joint right under the arm the tip
of his spear sliced right through his
chain mail and boiled leather
sir gregor gave a choke grunt as the
dornishmen twisted his spear and yanked
it free
elia say it elia of dorne he was
circling
with his spear ready for another thrust
say it
tyrion had his own prayer fall down and
die was how it went
damn you fall down and die there was now
blood running down from under sir
gregor's arm
this blood was his own and tyrion knew
it must have been bleeding even more
heavily under his armor
when he tried to take a step one knee
buckled tyrion thought he was going down
oberyn had already moved behind him he
shouted ellia of dorne
sir gregor began to turn but it was too
slow and too late
the spearhead went through the back of
his knee this time through the layers of
chain and leather
the mountain reeled swayed then
collapsed face first on the ground
his huge sword went flying from his hand
he then slowly rolled onto his back
oberyn flung away his own ruined shield
grabbed his spear with both hands
then sauntered away behind him gregor
let out a groan
oberyn spun around faster than he's
moved all day then he ran at his fallen
foe
elia he screamed as he drove this beard
down with the whole weight of his body
behind it
the crack of the ashwood's shaft
snapping was almost as sweet as sound as
cersei's whale
of fury and for an instant oberyn had
wings
the snake had vaulted over the mountain
tyrion thought four
feet of broken spear jutted from
clegane's belly as oberyn rolled
rose and dusted himself off he threw
aside the splintered spear and claimed
his foe's greatsword
if you die before you say her name sir i
will hunt you through all seven hells he
said
sir gregor attempted to rise the broken
spear had gone through him
into the ground holding him down he
wrapped both of his hands about the
shaft
grunting but could not get it out his
blood was spreading across the ground
beneath him
i am feeling more innocent by the
instant tyrion told alaria sand beside
him
oberyn move closer say the name he stuck
his foot on the mountain's chest and
raised the great sword with both hands
whether he intended to hack off gregor's
head or shove it through his eye slit
was something
tyrion would never know sir gregor's
hand shot up and grabbed the dornishmen
behind
the knee the red viper brought down the
greatsword in a wild slash but he was
off balance
and the edge did no more than leave
another dent in the mountain's armor
then the sword was forgotten as gregor's
hand tightened and twisted
yanking the dornishmen down on top of
him they wrestled in the dust and blood
the broken spear wobbling back and forth
tyrion saw with horror that the mountain
had wrapped
one big arm around oberyn drawing him in
close against his chest like a lover
elia of dorne they all heard sir gregor
say
when they were close enough to kiss his
deep voice
boomed within the helm he thrust his
free hand into oberyn's unprotected face
jamming his steel covered fingers into
the dornishman's eyes
then i raped her clegane slammed his
fist into the dornishman's mouth
making splinters of his teeth then i
smashed her head in
like this as he grew back his giant fist
the blood on his gauntlet seemed to
smoke in the cold dawn air
there was a sickening crunch elaria sand
wailed in shock
and tyrion's breakfast came boiling back
up he found himself on one knee
wretching bacon and sausage and apple
cakes and that double helping of fried
eggs cooked up with onions and fiery
dornish peppers
he never heard his father speak the
words that condemned him
maybe no words were necessary i'd laid
my life in the red viper's hands and he
dropped it
when he remembered too late that snakes
had no hands
tyrion began to laugh hysterically he
was halfway down the serpentine steps
before he realized that the gold cloaks
were not taking him back to his tower
room
the chapter ends when tyrion says i've
been consigned to the black cells
the gold cloaks did not bother to answer
why
waste your breath on the dead tyrion
thought
when ober and martel lost this fight in
the show it sort of did kill tyrion's
character in a sense
and let me explain what i mean by that
like i said when oberon lost in the
show tyrion was condemned by his father
which led to his brother jaime
setting him free as you all know once
tyrion was freed
he killed his former lover shay then he
killed his father tywin lannister
afterwards he could no longer live in
king's landing
now he had to live his life on the run
that is until he met daenerys targaryen
now this is only my opinion but the day
tyrion left king's landing was the day
his character died
think about it this is when he stopped
drinking he stopped visiting [ __ ]
houses
he stopped being funny he stopped being
clever and witty
he stopped having all those amazing
interactions with his other family
members
when all the lannisters were in the same
room together that made for some of the
greatest scenes in the show
but once tywin died in tyrion left
king's landing
all that stopped i could no longer
recognize all those characteristics that
made me love tyrion's character
those days were over all he was really
known for after this was making stupid
mistakes
so although he may not have died
physically he basically did die in every
other way imaginable
as i said before this was and still is
an incredible moment in the show
and in the books as well let me know how
you reacted when you first saw or read
that scene
i would love to hear from all of you
anyways i have to thank all of you for
watching my video
i hope everyone has a great day i will
see you again very soon bye
[Music]
you